we buy the house we build on coyote pass
you move into that house we rent this
house that's the plan with Robin's house
I just my heart I want a house I'm ready
to be settled in my own house yeah but
we're a year from that even if we start
building right away
yeah I just but Cody I don't think I can
do both
I I can't afford
both house mortgages I can't buy this
house and in any shape or form Finance
another house no matter even if it's
small like I I just can't
I don't know why we couldn't
okay all we got to do is get I so I
called kelly today because you and I
have been all this we just like we our
friends say this yeah yeah yeah you know
I mean and he said it would be two years
of renting this to somebody else oh it's
not a year
so Kelly is a mortgage professional here
in town that we've used for a lot of our
financing
and he said you would have to rent it
for two years before somebody would not
count that mortgage towards your debt to
income when you're trying to finance
something else
and I don't want this house I want to be
out on the property that's the whole
reason I
been doing everything I've been doing I
want to be out there
I still think you're not being
open-minded okay Cody I talked to Kelly
I know he says two years so what it
takes a whole year to build I'm not
gonna well no create the problem is I
wouldn't be able to build I can't even
get a construction loan if I buy this
house you know if Janelle wouldn't have
bought the RV she could have been able
to afford the mortgage on Christine's
house if we were able to pull out pay
off the land this year then why wouldn't
we be able to actually just fund your
construction next year no God
it's like no but it's like everybody's
lost sighted the reason that we moved
here was to build out there I I know but
this is I I I'm not saying we're not
building out there I'm saying we're
simply just buying an asset
it would be two years before I could
apply two years of rent so where am I
going to live for those two years
that we're renting this
I'm just being creative and a little bit
argumentative here with Janelle but the
whole point is I want to get her into a
home and Christine's house is here
available and easy
I can be built in a year
I just I see that we just lack
creativity here I understand what
Kelly's saying I want to go forward with
this build but I don't know why we would
not go forward because the money I'd
have to put is a down payment on this
would basically almost pay off the land
no I'm I'm we can do both I just I don't
think so
[Music]